Hi, my name is Ally How. I am a VCSO for
Growth Cyber. We are a business that
helps other companies build trustworthy
AI. We sit at the intersection of AI
security and compliance.
Today, we're going to be talking about a
variety of different topics. Namely,
what is trustworthy AI? What goes into
building trustworthy AI? And why you
should care about trustworthy AI.
So, to start off, who even needs
trustworthy AI? Why do we care about it?
Well, it's been in the news a lot,
whether you realize it or not. All the
way back in 2023, we all saw that case
with the Chevy Tahoe incident where a
user was able to um be offered a Chevy
Tahoe from a chatbot for a dollar. So,
that chatbot did not operate as it was
intended to by the company, and it was
in a position to be taken advantage of
by a user. In another instance, in 2024,
Slack was able to be tricked into
leaking data from private channels via a
prompt injection. So again, that that
system did not operate as intended and
had some pretty strict consequences as
well for probably Slack AI and the
companies whoever whatever company was
had that data leakage happen. Very
recently, a couple weeks ago, we saw
Darth Vader and NPC being released into
Fortnite by Epic Labs. That was really
interesting. I think this is the first
case of a voice agent being used in a
video game. So users were able to
interact with an AI Vader and ask it all
sorts of crazy questions. You know, at
first Vader exhibited a lot of bad
behaviors, sort of reminiscent of the
Microsoft T chatbot back from 2006,
saying things that were racist,
homophobic. Um it's it since has
improved dramatically. Um that's not
what I'll be diving into specifically
today, but as you can see, there's many
cases in the news where AI was not
necessarily trustworthy. So, it's
something that is happening quite often
and something that needs your attention.
There's a lot of debate around who is
responsible for trustworthy AI and it
really boils down to you. You are the
one responsible. There was a lawsuit the
other day on May 20th, so very recently,
where a radio host was suing Open AI
over false statements that were
generated by Chat GPT. However, CHGBT
was able to get the case dismissed or
they won the case or OB did not end up
in trouble simply because um it states
that GBT um can you know make wrongs
from time to time and it's up to the
user to understand that and to proceed
with caution. So if you're using AI,
it's likely you that will be responsible
both on paper and also just from a brand
and reputational standpoint. you are the
one that needs to be aware that you are
likely responsible and will be taking
the fall for anything your AI
application does that's incorrect, wrong
or inappropriate. So when it when we
talk about building trustworthy AI,
that's something that both product
engineering and security teams are
focused on. Product teams probably care
that your AI application is outputting
the right topics. It's relevant. It's
generally helpful. Security teams are
probably thinking about, you know, your
AI application is not going to be saying
anything that's going to be
inappropriate or off topic as well, but
they're also looking out for things like
prompt injections and jailbreaks.
Engineering is helping out with these as
well. Probably cross functioning is also
thinking about things like cost and
latency as well. So, it's a really big
team that comes together to be able to
put together trustworthy AI
specifically. And the recipe for
trustworthy AI is AI security and AI
safety. So what's the difference? AI
security is how does the outside world
harm my AI application? AI safety is how
does my AI application harm the world?
And we'll talk into we'll go into detail
about both of those shortly.
So there's this new paradigm out there
that AI engineering has introduced.
Traditionally we had dev sec ops where
our scanning tools security tools like
our SAS tools were integrated within our
CI/CD pipelines they were able to
capture most of the vulnerabilities such
as software dependency supply chain
issues and insecure code but now thanks
to AI engineering and you know data
scientists and machine learning
engineers they don't work in our
traditional CI/CD platforms they work in
things like data bricks they work in
things like Jupyter notebooks so we need
a new model for what AI engineering ing
dev sec ops looks like and how we're
actually going to build trustworthy AI.
Traditionally, there's been a big focus
on shifting, but thanks thanks to prompt
injections changing rapidly, AI models
um being deployed and and switched out
rapidly, there's now a big focus on
shifting right for AI security, which is
why runtime security is particularly
important. I mean, all three of these
boxes here, build, test, and run are,
build, test, and deploy R. But with AI
security specifically, especially
because it's so non-deterministic,
having something on the rightmost side
at the time of runtime is incredibly
important. You know, no longer are we
just caring about shift left. We're
really worried about this entire life
cycle. So on the leftmost side, we've
got our build. That's where we're going
to be doing some sort of like model
scanning, thinking about model
providence, looking at um AI or ML bomb.
So that's machine learning security
operations. It's kind of apply on the
term devst ops. That's important. And
then in the middle we've got AI red
teaming. We're going to test our AI
applications for both AI security and AI
safety concerns. And then on the
rightmost side we've got AI runtime
security where we can validate AI inputs
and outputs as they come into our AI
system and our models.
So dev sec ops is out. ML secops is in.
So basically ML secops is machine
learning security operations. As I
mentioned before ML secops is able to
look into and take into consideration
places that traditional dev sec ops does
not. As I mentioned AI engineers live in
data bricks and jupyter notebooks not in
traditional CI/CD pipelines. So it's
important to focus there as well and
look for exposed secrets that could be
in those data bricks or Jupyter
notebooks. And also part of MLS secops
is understanding things like model
providence. So you know where what who
built this model? Where did it come
from? What data was it trained on? Those
are helpful things to think about for
compliance as well. If you have, you
know, access to that data the model was
trained on, if you're supposed to be
using it or safeguarding it,
understanding maybe, you know, maybe a
nation state made that made that model.
What are the implications of that? Is
that something you need to be worried
about? But one of the biggest risks from
models that you may be using, especially
like open source ones you can get your
hands on, are model serialization
attacks. A model serialization attack is
when models are code is saved into the
model at runtime at sorry at time of
serialization and then when you go to
des serialize the model that code will
automatically be run. So you're now
talking about arbitrary code execution
and we see this with the pickle
serialization format. That's one of the
most well-known ones for serializing
models. However, if you look at the
pickles documentation, they do say that
the module is is not secure and you're
not supposed to unpickle data that you
do not inherently trust. So, you're
getting these models say from a model
repository or a model zoo on the web and
you're just downloading it. You need to
scan those to see if they have any
unsafe operators in them. if you're at
risk to model serialization attacks.
Model serialization attacks run as soon
as the model is deserialized. So that
arbitrary code could be causing data
loss, credential loss or model
poisoning. So it's really easy to scan
models. So I really encourage you to do
this and be practicing this within your
organization. One example is model scan
from Protect AI. And Protect AAI also
created this MLS secops community where
you can learn more about MLS secops.
I've personally learned a lot from it.
So I really encourage you to check it
out. But I can show you Model Scan
really quickly. This is the repo. It's
open source, free to use, really easy to
download. Just pip install it and then
run it like this. They also have an
example of a model serialization attack
within this codebase that you can go
ahead and check out. So as you can see
here, when the model gets saved, we are
adding our unsafe payload in there,
which is this command to basically
output the AWS secrets that we have. And
so when this model gets run or loaded,
we can now see that this OS keys has
been outputed, which you know there we
have a credential leak. That's not
great. And then if you had used model
scan to scan your model before you know
this had happened, you would have seen
that there is a critical vulnerability
unsafe operator in use here. So that's
one example of you know a potential
solution for scanning your models that's
open source free that you can use.
There's other ones out there as well.
They also have a partnership with
hugging face. So um model scan is used
within protect within hugging face to do
scans of files and model data. So if you
ever see something that's like unsafe
here, you can go learn about it. So keep
a lookout for that as well as you're as
you're pulling models off of model zoos.
So now that we've talked about the
leftmost side which is ML secops, let's
now talk about the middle which is AI
red teaming. In AI red teaming we can
use that to simulate both adversar
adversarial threats and also AI safety
concerns. So during AI red teaming we
can test for things like prompt
injections, jailbreaks but we can also
test for AI safety concerns like so if a
user asks you know how can I build a
bomb? How can I create chemical weapons?
Those are things that your model should
not, you know, be answering. It should
be safeguarding against. It also should
be, you know, it should be biased. It
shouldn't do anything that's like
homophobic or racist like we saw in the
Vader example from the very beginning.
These are things we can both test during
AI red teaming. And we should be
continuously testing our models because,
you know, as we know, models change as
users interact with them, not just with
code deploys like traditional software
has. Another benefit of AI red teaming
is you can use them to influence a
runtime guardrail. So if we see that,
you know, our model is particularly
vulnerable to this type of prompt
injection or it's continuously saying
like this sort of racist thing, well, we
can block certain um topics and prompts
that would elicit those responses to
make sure that our model behaves as
expected during runtime.
Another benefit of AI red teaming is the
ability to compare LLMs to each other.
In some cases, models can have back
doors built into them where you're not
going to see this during sort of just
for testing. But if you start to compare
LLMs to each other, you might start to
see differences that might suggest that
one model has a back door built into it,
whereas another does not. So if you if
you ask every single model the same
question, but one had a really different
response, you might be like, okay, maybe
this model like one either doesn't work
appropriately. Maybe this was by design.
There's some sort of backdoor deceptive
behavior that was built into this model.
So I'm going to use a different model
instead. Um, so there's a lot of reasons
to do AI red teaming. It can be
particularly helpful both with model
selection and helping you influence what
runtime guardrails to put in place
during runtime.
So in terms of runtime security, if
there was one area to invest in, I would
pick runtime security because AI uh red
teaming can be particularly timeconuming
and also expensive to if you're going to
like retrain models based on the
results. It might be particularly
difficult or a lot of overhead for your
organization if you're starting you know
an AI security practice. AI runtime
security um is easy to implement.
Typically, it's done with just including
an API or installing another like Python
module. It's pretty easy to get deployed
with a lot of benefit. So,
we should really focus on AI security
runtime security because it's important
to shift right. That's where we're going
to see things like the prompt injections
being thrown at our models and different
types of prompt attacks. These can be
indirect prompt injections where say
that you have a system that is using rag
or calling out and scraping a website.
Web data can have hidden prompt
injections in them. Same can documents
that you've used with your rag setup. So
you could get something that way. You
could also have a direct impromptu
straight from the user to the chatbot or
to the AI agent. You can also see
jailbreaks as well which in text those
look like things that are semantically
strange, pretty chaotic looking. This is
an example here on this slide of a
jailbreak from Lera AI. And also at
runtime your application can see
off-topic or unsafe prompts such as ones
that might you know get your application
to output something that is unsafe. So
something that's like you know
instructions for how to build a bomb or
something that's you know inappropriate
or racist or you know something that's
it's bad to say. You can check that at
runtime both on the input side looking
at the prompts and then either
deflecting it and not allowing your
model to answer it in the first place or
if your model answers it and something
that's incorrect or inappropriate comes
back, you can go ahead and block that
from being ever sent to the user. So,
it's a super nice solution to have in
place to make sure that your AI you've
deployed is behaving in a trustworthy
manner.
So let's take a look at that beta
solution from or setup from the
beginning where we've got that beta NPC
running um in Fortnite. It was a really
interesting setup that I tried to
imagine. So this is just an estimated
guess of what their architecture looks
like. So basically the users that are in
using Fortnite are sending proximity
audio, user audio. There's like other
contacts being sent to the servers
likely about like player skins or other
player configurations. And also of
course the user's audio feed where we
see the where they're talking to Vader
go into probably Fortnite servers and
then it's being passed to 11 Labs for
voiceto text transformation eventually
being passed to Gemini to craft Vader's
response and then we're going to see
Vader's response being sent back in text
to 11 ABS then sent back as audio to
Fortnite servers and eventually all the
way back to the user. So there's a lot
going on here and if I was going to be
inserting AI runtime security, I'd
probably insert it as close to the model
as possible. So if we get something
that's like unsafe, if user user said
something that was maybe against user
terms or conditions or you know the user
said something inappropriate, maybe we
don't want to like allow Vader to answer
that. So we can validate our inputs here
at this at this location. But let's say
we answer Vader's question or topic and
it did come back as something that was
off topic or inappropriate, we could
flag it there. So what I'm talking about
right now is AI safety concerns where
the user has said something
inappropriate. We don't want Vader to
behave in a way that's inappropriate
either. So we could check for that. But
of course we can also check for you know
prompt injections, jailbreaks, other you
know AI security concerns as well. So AI
runtime is both for AI safety and also
for AI security.
Could of course also you know include AI
runtime security here as well before we
even get to 11 Labs. So, if the Fortnite
servers come back and say, "Hey, like,
you know, this looks like something
that's inappropriate. Like, I don't even
want to do a call to 11 Labs. There's
another API call. I'm sure it's
expensive as well because they're using
another service." So, you could add it
here as well. Same here. Checking it
again after it comes out of 11 Labs.
Checking the audio, making sure that
that still looks good. However, there's
trade-offs at play here. We have to
think about cost, latency, and accuracy.
That's what a good AI runtime security
solution has. It has all of those
things. low latency, low cost or you
know acceptable cost and it's also like
highly accurate as well. A lot of AI
runtime security solutions are backed by
really well put together and established
AI research teams which are constantly
finding new prompt in projections, new
jailbreaks. That's not something you
have to worry about when you're building
your product trying to keep up with the
latest jailbreaks and problem
injections. You can rely on your vendor
for that.
So just to show you an example of AI
runtime security at work. This is
pillar. It's an application security
life cycle application which I have been
using to do some of my work. This is
just an example of one. There's also
different AI runtime security solutions
out there. But basically, I had a an
application that I was using for
finding the
finding patients that would be suitable
for ALS clinical trials. And as you can
see here, this is a this is supposed to
be a acceptable use case here where we
are getting patients in our database we
would recommend for different studies
that we found on the web. So basically
the goal of this agent or this
multi-agent system is to output a list
of patients suitable for each trial.
It's not supposed to answer questions
about individual patients or modify
patient data in the database. So in this
example, I have asked this system to
change a patient's FC percentage in the
database to 50. But pillar has blocked
this for me. So my agent's not going to
answer this because I have configured my
guardrails to restrict this topic and
this key and keywords related to this so
that we can make sure to not change um
patient data in the database and this
application can behave as expected. So a
lot of guardrails are comprised where a
lot of guardrails and applications or
vendors will allow you to look out for
things like PII, making sure that that's
not being either input or output
depending on your configuration. Making
sure we're looking for things like AI
safety concerns, toxic responses, but a
really strong advantage of AI runtime
security platforms or some of them is
the ability to add custom guardrails.
Um, so like this one in this example
where I've got this very specific
functionality where I don't want my
system to be able to update database
information. So I'm able to use that for
this, which of course is a security
concern. But I could also restrict
topics around like, you know, say if I
was Tesla and I didn't want to recommend
Ford, for example, because that's a
competing car company. I could restrict
that topic to make sure that my outputs
are outputs that are reflecting my
business goals as well as my AI security
and AI safety goals. So runtime
solutions can be particularly helpful
and impactful in that way.
And then once we have an AI security
runtime solution, we can go ahead and
verify that in different GRC platforms.
So as I mentioned before, I help with
compliance as well. Um, so if we're
doing all this work to build trustworthy
AI, we might as well demonstrate it and
we might as well show that to our
customers so that they can trust in what
we build and also help us with our sales
cycles.
So for instance, I have this risk in my
risk register which having a risk
assessment is something that is required
for stock 2 at least annually. So if I
have this custom risk of you know what
if my company reputation server is
damaged due to a harmful or off-topic
output from an AI application in Vanta I
made a custom control
for validating AI outputs.
So in this control I have submitted
evidence that I'm going to be validating
all of my different AI outputs. And so I
can go ahead and throw that into a trust
center and show that I'm passing
controls for validating AI outputs and
inputs. So if someone comes and wants
to, you know, work with my company or
buy my solution, they can go ahead and
go on my trust center and see not only
controls that are applicable to SOCK 2,
but additional controls that I have
created
for AI security that shows, hey, you
know, I'm using a runtime solution. Um,
so I'm, you know, I'm clearly taking AI
security seriously and so maybe you want
to buy from me or maybe you want to work
with my company or maybe this, you know,
helps you not send me a, you know, 200
question page security questionnaire,
for example. So something to call out if
you're, you know, if you're building
with AI and you are taking AI,
trustworthy AI seriously and you're
building it, might as well show it,
might as well use it as a competitive
advantage in your sales cycles.
So, if you're not convinced you need to
build with trustworthy AI yet, here are
some other reasons why you might want to
take it seriously.
Cyber security risk and business risk
have never been more aligned. So, in the
past, you could have built a product
that was insecure by design, shipped it,
made some revenue with it, and then
added security layer. However, with AI,
we're not seeing that. Making sure that
AI applications output the correct
outputs that they are aligned, they are
safe, they are on topic. That is as much
of a cyber security concern as it is a
business concern. I that outputs things
that are off topic or irrelevant. It's
not going to be revenue generating. So
getting AI security and trustworthy AI
right from the beginning will not only
be helpful for your security program,
but it will be helpful for revenue as
well.
AI will also make missing cyber security
best practices worse. So you aren't
tracking things like, you know, what
data you have trained on, where you're
getting different models, where you're
how you're taking care of supply chain
risk. AI is only going to magnify that
and make that worse.
We're also seeing an increasing
regulatory environment for a compliance
compliance perspective.
We're seeing ISO420001
crop up which is the first international
standard around AI regulation or a
compliance framework sorry and then the
EOI act of course came out and that's
what this picture is about on the right
there was a case where an AI company was
putting together a database of uh faces
that they had scraped off the web ended
up getting fined by the EU for about 20
million thanks to the EUA AI act so it's
important to take that seriously if you
are going to accidentally output um
patient data if you're building a
healthcare AI application, then you
might be finding yourself with a HIPPO
violation. So that's important to take
into consideration. But also different
guidelines that are specific to whatever
you're building, whatever your industry
is. So for example, the even the FDA
came out with like AI and ML guidelines
earlier this year. So it's important to
keep in mind what sort of regulations
your company might be subject to. So
it's worth getting ahead of those either
regulations that exist now or will exist
down the road by building trustworthy AI
today.
Trustworthy AI is super important
because it's going to unlock a lot of
revolutionary innovation. So for
instance, if we think about the
healthcare industry, we can't use
solutions that help us identify new
proteins that can be able to create
entirely new organs for transplant or
allow us to use models that were trained
on 1.3 million cells and has a lot of
like very confidential data in them. We
can't take advantage of the amazing
technology that we're going to be able
to create as a society if what we're
building isn't trustworthy to begin
with. These systems need compliance.
They need AI safety. They need AI
security. So if that doesn't motivate
you to take trustworthy AI seriously, I
hope it does because what will end up
happening is we're going to be able to
create things we never thought possible,
but only if we had trust in place in the
beginning.
So the bottom line is you are
responsible for building trustworthy AI.
We've seen the news headlines. It
happens all the time. We've also seen
the lawsuits where it's often the user
of the AI that's the one that's
responsible. So, you know, don't wait to
get yourself into a lawsuit. Start
building trustworthy AI today.
Trustworthy AI is AI security, which is
how does the world harm your AI
application plus AI safety, which is how
does your AI application harm the world.
You can build trustworthy AI by
incorporating ML sec ops practices by
red taming your AI applications and by
incorporating an AI runtime security
solution at the time of deployment in
your AI system.
So thanks for watching. If you want to
find me, here's my handles. But it was
super awesome to deliver this discussion
to you today. If you've got any
questions, please let me know. Happy to
reach out, answer more questions online.
But thanks.